it's time
for tonight's #HashtagWars.
(cheering)
This may not come
as any surprise to you,
but this year's
presidential nominees
are the least popular
of all time.
One of the main things
people are saying is that, uh,
they're gonna be voting
for the lesser of two evils.
But if we vote
for the lesser of two evils,
we still end up with-- an evil.
-(laughter)
-Uh...
but there have
to be better reasons
for electing the next president
of our United States of America.
That's why tonight's hashtag is
#ImVotingBecause.
And it's very important,
you need to get out and vote,
you need to get out and vote
or you can't (bleep) complain.
-(cheering, applause)
-That's it. You can't...
you don't get to complain.
It is...
it is our right as Americans
to bitch
as long as you vote.
As long as you vote,
you can bitch all you want.
So, examples might be-- I want
to feel superior to teens,
or, I'm gonna use that "I voted"
sticker to cover a scar.
I put 60 seconds on the clock,
and begin.
-Johnathan. -I'm voting
because I look like this.
-All right, points.
-(laughter, whooping, applause)
Alice.
-Wait, when is it?
-Uh, points.
-Uh, Johnathan.
-I'm voting because if I don't,
my 12 Years a Slave
screenplay book club
-would be very upset with me.
-All right, points.
Alice Wetterlund.
Um, I heard 3K
and an "I voted" sticker
-gets you into Hamilton.
-All right, points.
-Jordan.
-I'm voting because feminism
is the new patriarchy,
and I'm here for it.
-WETTERLUND: Whoo!
-All right, points.
-Alice Wetterlund.
-Okay, okay, I'm voting
because there's a difference
between unpopular and evil.
-All right. Points.
-Okay.
-(applause)
-Jordan.
I'm voting because these fingers
are not for picking,
-they're for rolling, okay?
Um... -All right, points.
-(applause)
-Johnathan.
I'm voting because
I have Tuesday off, so...
Yeah, okay, points.
Yeah, (bleep). Come on.
Yeah, Jordan.
I'm voting because
my Mexican mechanic
said he'd give me a deal
if I did.
HARDWICK:
All right, points.
Points. Alice.
Uh, I like saying
I did a civic duty.
HARDWICK:
Yes, points.
(laughing):
You, good answer.